one of the things I love that you talk
about is like how do we raise kids to be
creators entrepreneurs producers like
things or people who can create things
right and so like what is that solution
we talk about the problems but like what
is the solution or what does that design
look like for how kids can learn yeah so
again in school a lot of what kids are
doing for 12 years like that's a long
time is they are again following
instructions and really like working
through this worksheets and like
make-believe projects and things that
are just real in the school environment
it's like that's the reality like very
rarely do you see kids actually going
out and solving a problem in the real
world or things that are relevant right
so it's interesting cuz to me a good
education is one that where kids leave
or they graduate you know being
extremely aware of what they're good at
having had plenty of experience creating
and building different things on failing
and then trying again and getting
feedback until they nail something and
then you know and having that desire to
keep learning and those three things are
not happening right now and the one the
one that we're talking about right now
is like how do you get more kids to
create well giving them the opportunity
to create things so I recently like sent
out a tweet storm with David of Y
Combinator and how you know I just find
it fascinating that model cuz that's how
kind of like how I envisioned kids you
know a school nowadays right if you want
to call it a school but a place where
you know kids go and they're putting two
teams depending on what they're
interested in they have this idea as
they balance off ideas and they just
start building things and then every two
weeks they have check-in points and they
get feedback and then you know they see
what works they test it and then they
build again and and you know they need
more opportunities to do these things
and just build and create and create and
we don't give them that space in school
in school they're sitting down learning
from a curriculum so I'm really
interesting in in creating that space
and and you know before kovat happened
like I was already thinking about doing
it in the online space just so that kids
from different countries could just join
and then it's a space for kids to create
different things they come in with a
problem that they want to solve and I
help them and I provide them with the
resources so that they
worked it through and come up with a
prototype and solve a problem that
they're interested in a real problem and
I feel like I've seen how through that
process they're learning so many you
know so many things they're learning how
to do research how we like talk about
their ideas how to incorporate feedback
and change things and to me that is the
kind of learning that is gonna be more
valuable for kids in the future right
forget about what's going on in school
we've already talked about how that's
like they're not preparing kids for the
future but if we open more centers or
you know creative studios or like I'm
doing online spaces for kids to just go
in and execute their ideas and try them
out two things are gonna happen one we I
do feel like we're gonna have more kids
that are fifteen sixteen like with their
own company so with their own products
out there because they're gonna have
tried so many times and I don't have you
seen a kid when they're into something
they won't stop until they get to what
they want to so it's a matter of
providing them to space and the
resources to create and create and
create and create and and that's kind of
like a makerspace
right for kids so that's kind of what
I'm envisioning that kids think more
nowadays and hopefully more people start
doing things like this so one of the
things I've always been fascinated by is
I think a disproportionate amount of
CEOs and founders of very large tech
companies as kids went to monastery
schools and I am definitely not an
expert on these Montessori schools but
my understanding is that it's very much
less rigid it's more kind of this group
project based type learning it's a
little bit self-directed by the kids
what are you interested what do you not
interested and also one of the most
fascinating person I was reading about
is like the way that they address the
students right so your students we're
calling you miss fab like they would
just use first names right and it almost
treat the adult as a peer in some way I
think a lot of you would get scared by
that they're like oh my god how could
you ever you know kind of break down the
hierarchical structure but also it looks
like it works like there's a certain
type of person that comes out the other
end of that process and so it almost
feels like what you're talking about is
taking that type of more free-flowing
less rigid structure but focusing it
specifically on like creation right like
how do you build how do you build is
that a fair kind of assessment yeah
yeah absolutely so so I'm a big fan of
Montessori schools and uh you know there
are other kind of approaches that are
similar that are very student-centered
and that the kid is doing most of the
learning like Reggio Emilia you have wal
d'oeuvres so there are I'm a big fan and
that's actually where I'm pulling you
know many of my ideas from because it's
around this idea that we want the kid to
learn so what can we do for the kid to
want to learn and I feel like it's you
know it's a lot more fun kids enjoy
going to this kinds of schools a lot
more what I fear though is and which is
one of the reasons why I'm trying the
online space is that the most privileged
kids are really the ones who get access
to this kind of educational experiences
right and this experiments that are
going on and the ones that are the least
advantage are the ones who kind of like
get stuck in this system and and that's
something that's constantly in my mind I
obviously don't have an answer for that
but one of the things that I was
thinking is well I believe that you know
more and more people are gonna have
access to an internet connection in the
future right like it's just becoming
more and more common even in remote
areas and of course this is not to say
everyone but I feel like I I'm really
interested in exploring the online space
cuz I have a feeling that we can
recreate this Montessori approached
learning experiences in the online space
and have access to more kids right and
to kids that you know may not have a
Montessori School clothes wherever they
live but definitely I think their mind
is in the right place
and and I'm a big fan of all you know
all these experiments that are have been
done around that space